[Music]
to an Anthem of Revolution and into a
sea of his most loyal supporters please
welcome the next president and first
lady of the United States of America the
former president with his pitch to be
the next one America's comeback starts
right now
for over an hour he spoke it was a
vision of his America against today's
America his achievements against Biden's
challenges
China Russia Iran and North Korea were
in check
and respect it they respected the United
States and quite honestly they respected
me he dismissed the many legal
investigations against him and I'm a
victim I will tell you and the fact that
his candidates were so often not the
chosen ones in last week's midterms well
that's fake news he said and then the
moment they'd been waiting for in order
to make America great and glorious again
I am tonight announcing my candidacy for
president of the United States
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
the foot soldiers of the trumpism
movement
only the most loyal here of course but
this does stretch across the country and
it cuts into society
so many times the Republican Party
establishment has tried to cut Trump
loose after the January the sixth
Insurrection and many trumpian moments
in between they try and they try but
they just can't let him go because they
know that this Remains the reality
denying force behind the party he
deserves another shot the fir the second
election was rigged from him
um they really believe that of course I
believe it have you seen all of the
fraud out of Arizona look what happened
right now man this is tremendous maybe
we can correct all the things that
that Joe Biden's done wrong now we had
to do it once now we're going to get to
do it again
that loyalty can't simply be switched
off or directed Elsewhere for as long as
they stand by the man in the palace
behind them he'll continue to be a force
Mark Stone Sky News at Mar-A-Lago in
Florida
[Music]